hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's bought night update time again we
are now moving into week 9 of the season
which has been extended by another month
but don't worry about that we've been
promised lots of updates between now and
then if you're new around these parts
this is the show where we look at all
the map updates changes and secrets and
share them no matter how inconsequential
they are so slap code alum arrow in the
star to support this series and the like
and subscribe thing really helps too but
that's way too much begging let's do
this
[Music]
as always I first checked on our Lord
and Savior Graham the genome he's doing
really well in his ivory tower and a
quick thank you to those people who let
me know that the G in genome is actually
silent I had no idea thank you so much
anyway we'll check up on his brothers
soon I'm going to lazy lake have you
spotted a new building here it's none
other than no sweat insurance if you
don't recognize it let's take a trip
down memory lane back in Chapter 1
there was one building until to towers
which always crumbled to the ground
many store owners renovated and moved
back in there only for another disaster
to hit but then the insurance company
named no sweat moved in their speciality
was protecting buildings from
annihilation we all thought this was a
futile endeavor especially when the
volcano event began the entire of tilted
towers was reduced to rubble every last
building well not every last building
because somehow no sweat insurance
survived completely completely untouched
and is now known as the luckiest
business ever created but I guess it
wasn't that lucky because we all were
sucked into a black hole at the end yeah
not that lucky
now a whole eight months later they have
finally been pulled through the black
hole and set up shop in lazy Lake inside
the building it's only just beginning to
fill up and they're awesome diorama
hasn't moved in just yet but I'm sure it
will one day but here's where this
becomes interesting all around the
island we can find signposts for the
company they are getting their name out
there and offering help to inhabitants
to survive the impending doomsday event
but who will be saved
will we be choosing who gets saved I
cannot wait to find out aft of interest
what building or area would you save
from destruction I would have said risky
reals but if you've been there over the
last week you now know it's sadly just a
digital billboard for struggling TV
shows bad times I'm choosing to remember
this place for the Star Wars event or my
personal favorite that one time wreck-it
Ralph showed up without warning man
those were good memories also people are
commenting that all these signs are
indicating where the new tilted towers
will
drop imagine that next another long
story of chairs and pallets back in
season one a group of chairs were
assembled and rounded up at the docks
and slowly began to be transported
around the islands we all attempted to
predict their destination at a similar
point another truck began moving in the
opposite direction
this one had wood pallets upon its back
they must be going to the same location
we are force well we were more right
than we ever could have imagined
take a look at the carnage this week
what a disaster both trucks have smashed
into each other and debris is scattered
everywhere but look we can already see
what this may become the chairs and
pallets will likely become a new
landmark I don't want to jinx things
just yet
but maybe this is the fable of hot watch
version 2.0 the biblical story told from
father to son told from mother to
daughter
for generations if you don't believe me
just check the comments cut wash for
life
it's everywhere what the cult has a new
focal point let's check back next update
[Music]
something strange happened over its
slurpy over the last four weeks there
once was a bridge of sauce which was no
big deal
it was run-of-the-mill boring bridge and
then a few updates back it was
completely filled in without warning
what could this mean maybe a test for a
flood event
well last update it changed again the
bridge is back I can't explain this I
hope you can but I thought it should go
in the video all the same whilst here it
looks like Deadpool is using pio eyes to
clean his spare suits just like the one
at the yacht's Deadpool has made flags
around the island even the agency has
one in its sights there's one at 20
cents - what is the Merc with a mouth
doing and by the way I made a special
episode of this series to show you all
the awesome details on Deadpool's yacht
I'll be sure to link it at the end of
the video if you want to see some cool
Deadpool stuff
and now the storyline that has kept us
in thrall for seasons the war between
the misfits and the gnome army last week
we saw grams mythical twin brother who
was named by you guys as gandalf
keemstar jerome the genome i still love
that big gandalf was imprisoned by the
evil misfits in a secret bunker under
the forest the misfits appeared over
Christmas time and began hatching a plan
to take over the island upon hearing
this news Graham sent his army to rescue
Gandalf and last week the army was
poised ready to attack this week from
the outside the gnomes have gone the
explosive Ram raid was successful so
let's venture inside there has indeed
been a battle here the gnome army has
come in and absolutely destroyed The
Misfits Gandalf is free and as we speak
is deciding what action to take against
the misfit leader hang on this bird
needs a name please do me the honor in
the comments below
name the leader of the misfit bears
looking around down here we see that the
gnomes have chosen to leave all the
misfits alive in a prison cell which
once held Gandalf in there they are
reminded of what will happen if they
attempt to escape but hang on we can
interact with that bear this storyline
is not over yet
what will happen next press like and
subscribe to find out some sad news now
we also must take a moment out to
celebrate the life of this little gnome
here he didn't survive the siege he lays
crushed under a server rack rest in
peace unnamed gnome 26 will never forget
you dude but this is a time for
celebration we're going to concentrate
on this norm instead little Norman
tucking in to a honey pot the spoils of
war cute lil bugger if you ever wondered
what victory tastes like honey I'm
guessing
[Music]
he's a very small change you can see
right now in-game get your butt over to
the agency and look closely at the silos
or those hidden hatches in the water
they are beginning to glow purple in
replay mode we can actually get inside
this what does it look like to you is
this Kevin juice
have they been mining this under the
ground something is happening here the
area is powering up and due to the extra
month of the season this will likely be
a very slow change so let's keep an eye
on it another peculiar change can be
spotted up at whiskey reels bright pink
teddy bears in fact thick bright pink
teddy bears these guys are really
packing it a family of four are enjoying
risky reels and having a barbecue the
funny thing is we can lift these so I
took one for a day out he had a great
time I wonder if these thick boys are
going to be part of the gnome war so we
need to get ourselves up to this week's
main change-up at the shark but on the
way I took a trip to the crashed plane
island and can confirm nature is
continuing to take back the island
slowly growing further and further
around the ironwork and each week a new
crustacean joined the party look at his
little face this one's at my foot narnun
and this one's my favorites
please don't hurt him
[Music]
and now the shark update oh wow what a
huge change the shark is now a prison a
ghost prison by the looks of it so I
guess we all chose Sky's ghost variant
over her shadow variants I was expecting
this change so I took a few shots of the
old shark layout including Sky's awesome
room here's a montage of the old shark
[Music]
but now the shark is a great mess this
looks like it's going to be father new
mold epic have been testing in Thailand
where one person plays a mastermind
villain and others must escape the
prison that could be a great game mode
we have multiple cells here an outdoor
fitness area and check this out a
basketball court where if you've got
skills like me you can hit shots like
this off inside someone has already
escaped blowing a huge hole in the wall
but look closely they left a clue for us
a calendar what could this mean a
birthday cake on the 9th pizza on the 24
and on the 31st escape tape
hmm can anyone decipher this but by far
the coolest thing of note here is the
solitary cell just to the north the
maximum security cell has someone too
dangerous to be kept near others it's
like magneto cell what the heck will
happen here story theorists this is your
time to shine why is there a solitary
cell all by itself I think that's
everything that came in today but before
we go let's quickly look back at things
that were added last week alongside the
Deadpool update first me all souls took
up a new home down at the Box Factory
every so often we could see him cry
after being kicked out of the yacht
bad times brother he moved him pretty
well he's got all the items he needs
like his very important toilets also I
was talking to people about his name now
CIL's can you be honest here
do you cook do you call him now CIL's or
do you call him musicals yeah even a lot
of people have heard of go musicals I
like that is a better name perhaps I
track also last week we saw the sword in
the stone update for skies challenges
looking at the design it's safe to say
this is a Legend of Zelda reference as
it does look a lot like the Master Sword
that link picked up in the n64 version
of the game nice to touch epic so there
we have it all the changes in week 9 of
fortnight chapter 2 season 2 did I miss
anything
a quick thank you to those who support
me in the fortnight shop in particular a
thanks to these people on screen now the
legends roll call
they sent me a Twitter DM after picking
something up in the store I'm currently
about 6 days behind on my DM so if you
don't see your name here and very sorry
I will get to you you have my word your
name will be in the next video thanks
for staying till the end much love much
appreciated I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade stay awesome see you soon
[Music]